we need your membership okay we just do
right now we have the best deal of the
year it's 50 off four new members at
dw50 but here's the thing it's not just
you get all the great content you know
the extra stuff with me hanging out with
me as an all-access member for example
or watching canvas's show or becoming
part of the sweet baby gang with matt
walsh it's that you make a difference
with your help we've made so much of a
difference this year we needed your help
to do it we did so much i probably won't
even be able to remember everything that
we did you know we've got investigative
journalism we're exposing things in the
public school system and we've got big
plans for 2022 we've got movies coming
out joe biden came in and demanded that
we all take the fouchy algae well
because of you because of your support
we were able to sue the biden
administration where the lead plaintiff
taking on the biden administration right
now join the fight it really is a fight
you
have to be reading the papers you have
to be watching the news you have to be
seeing what's happening you make all of
that possible your membership we need
your help we need you join the fight
alongside us we really appreciate all
you do you make all of this possible
keep making it possible become a member
today